هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انه
حزين جدا لرؤيه الدمار الذي خلفته الزلازل
في تركيا مشيرا الى التزام بلاده ببدل كل
ما بوسعها للمساعده في جهود الانقاذ
والاغاثه
وكان قد تفقد مع نظيره التركي مولود شاويش
خلال جوله بطائره مروحيه الوضع في المدن
المنكوبه التي اصابها الزلزال في تركيا
عصب بلينكن الى قاعده في اضنه الجنوبيه
تركيا في زياره تستمر يومين وعند المفترض
ان يتجه غدا الاثنين الى انقره
وهناك يبحث مع نظيره التركي الدعم الذي
تقدمه واشنطن
لمتضرر زلزال
المنظمات للمساعدات للشمالي الغربي سوريا
يواجهوا تحديات عده مضاف في كلمه من قاعده
انجر جنوبيه تركيه ان هناك محاولات من
روسيا وغيرها من الدول لعدم اتاحه نقاط
عبور اخرى
فيما يتعلق بايصال المساعدات الى سوريا
هناك تحد كبير التحدي للمنظمات ومن يقدمون
المساعدات هو الدخول والوصول تم تقييد
عبور مساعدات الامم المتحده عبر نقطه عبور
واحده هناك محاولات من روسيا وغيرها من
الدول لعدم اتاحه نقاط عبور اخرى الحكومه
السوريه قالت انها ستوفر ممرات عبور اخرى
للامم المتحده لكن علينا ان نرى ذلك على
الارض نحاول ان نعزز المساعده الدمار في
سوريا كبير وسنعمل على ان لا تعطل اي
عقوبات مفروضه على سوريا وصول المساعدات
هذا لا شك فيه